What I want to do in this video
is think a little bit
about the estate tax.
As the name of the tax implies,
it is a tax on someone's estate
or when someone passes away,
it is a tax on what they
want to leave behind
to whoever they want to leave it to
either in their will or in their family
or whoever they want to
leave their stuff to.
Sometimes it's referred
to as an inheritance tax
and sometimes you'll
hear it talk this ways
on the news,
maybe it's a little bit derisive.
It's called a death tax.
The general idea, let's say that right now
my entire net worth,
I am worth $3 million
and then I pass away.
This $3 million goes into my estate.
This is my estate.
So this $3 million could
be all of my savings,
could be my stock portfolio,
it could be the value of my land,
my real estate.
Everything I own.
My car.
Everything combined is worth $3 million.
It goes into my estate after I pass.
Let's say I leave everything in my estate
to my daughter.
I leave it to my daughter.
It's at this point that the
estate tax comes into question
of how much money will my daughter get.
It turns out for $3 million
my daughter is exempt for
inheritance from an individual.
The first $5 million are exempt.
In this situation where I'm
leaving $3 million for my daughter
she actually will get
the entire $3 million.
If, let's say I'm even richer than that.
Let's say that I have $6 million.
Let's say the scenario
where I have $6 million
it all goes to my estate after my death
and now the first $5 million is exempt.
Let me write my daughter over here.
My daughter will get the
first 5 million tax free
and then the increment
above that exemption,
the increment above what has been excluded
will then be taxed at a certain rate
and that rate is constantly changing.
For the sake of simplicity
I'm going to go with the 35%
and that's actually the rate in 2011.
The rest of the 1 million,
the 1 million taxed at 35%.
The federal government will
tax 35% of the 1 million.
They will essentially take
350,000 for themselves
and my daughter will be
left with 5,650,000, right?
Because of this million
you'd take out 350,000,
you have 650,000 left.
My daughter in this situation
will be left with $5.65 million.
The federal government took 350,000.
If I am super rich, let's
say that I am worth,
let me make a number to make the math easy
so that I don't have to
get a calculator out.
Let's say that I am worth $1,005,000,000.
This is my net worth.
In this situation, the first
5 million will be excluded.
My daughter will get
the 5 million directly,
that will be excluded.
Then everything above that
will be taxed at the 35%.
In this situation you have
$1 billion taxed at 35%.
1 billion at 35%.
In this scenario the federal government
will take $350 million
and so that would leave of this billion
650 million left my daughter.
In total, she would get this 650 million
plus the 5 million that was excluded.
She would end up with a
total of $655 million.
I wouldn't feel too bad for her,
she should be pretty okay.
That's just how the estate tax works
and these examples I
gave with the 5 million
that is excluded,
this is for an individual
when they pass away.
If it's being done as a couple,
this exemption is actually 10 million.
Between my wife and I,
we have $1,005,000,000.
Let's say I pass away and we
own everything collectively.
She actually gets the
extra joint exemption
passed on to her.
Then if and when she passes away,
this would be $10 million
that will be tax free.
In this scenario, if this
is being done as a couple
my daughter would get
the entire $6 million.
The interesting thing about the estate tax
is it's highly contested.
People always debate, is
it wrong or is it right?
I'll talk to you on that a little bit.
I'll let you decide for yourself.
But I'll give, at least, in what I hear
is the main arguments for
or against the estate tax.
Like most taxes, there's always someone
who will believe that it is unfair.
Let me write the for and against.
For and against the estate tax.
Some people say it's unfair,
"Look. Over the course of my life
"I earned all of these money.
"I paid all of these income taxes
"off of the money I earned
"and now the stuff that I want
to leave behind to my children
"I am not able to leave it all to them.
"Because obviously $655
million is not enough.
"They deserve the entire
$1,005,000,000 for being my child."
So there's this argument that it is unfair
or it's some double taxation.
The money was taxed the
first time it was earned
and now it's being taxed again
once it's being inherited.
The counter argument to that
is double taxation is
everywhere in our society.
Corporations pay taxes
and then they give dividends
and the stock holders pay taxes again
and that's an exchange for
having the limited liability
of the corporation.
You pay taxes on your income
and then with that after tax income
you go buy something at the store,
once again, you pay sales tax.
Double taxation, it happens everywhere.
The for argument and
somewhat the counter argument
against the unfairness of it all is that,
"Look. We're exempting,"
depending on how you view it,
"the first $5 million or $10 million."
$5 million to $10 million is exempt.
The person who's for the
estate tax would say look,
it's a little disingenuous
when you make this
impression that your children
are going to suffer.
They're not going to be
able to get your house
or they're not going to
be able to get your car.
They're going to be
able to get all of that
as long as it's worth
less than $10 million
which is not a small amount of money.
Even above that, they're going
to get 65% of everything.
It's not like your children
are going to be left hungry
because of the estate tax.
It's actually a very
small number of people
that the estate tax will
even hit, really, the rich
because even the upper-middle class,
very few of them will leave
more than $10 million behind.
The other argument is,
if you're going to tax anything.
What to tax?
Do you tax income?
Obviously, you do have to
tax income to some degree
to get enough revenue for
the federal government.
Isn't it better to tax someone
who did not work for the money?
Someone who's getting the money, I mean,
maybe they already got every
other privilege in life.
They went to the best
schools and all the rest
and through connections, maybe, good jobs.
Why not tax the person
who is already lucky to
some degree by virtue of,
and this is just the
argument someone would make.
By the way, they're sill going
to get a lot of that money.
It's not like they're
going to be left poor.
They're still going to be fine.
To some degree, maybe if
they have a little bit less
it will be more of an
incentive for them to work.
The other argument for the estate tax,
and this is a broader,
almost a macro view of things
of what might be good for society
is if you don't have an estate tax
and we know that there's this
huge fortunes in the world
where someone creates
a big business empire
and they have billions
upon billions of dollars.
If someone has $10 billion,
and let's say they don't
have that many children
that they leave it behind to.
Maybe they only have one child
and they leave that $10
billion to that one child.
Then that one child can
literally just let that income
passively earn interest.
They'll never have to work
the rest of their life
and through the passive
earnings of just the assets
being invested,
over the course of that child's life
might grow to $30 billion.
It will definitely grow faster
than the economy itself.
Then that child, if
they have no estate tax,
they'll pass the $30
billion to their children
and then that will grow.
What you would have happening
generation after generation
is this family, if you
say the person who sets up
the empire.
Let's say this is the
entire country's GDP.
Right where the empire sets
up in this person's lifespan,
this is their proportion of the GDP
and this is just for simplicity.
If you don't tax it and just
passively over the course
of the next lifespan,
if there aren't enough offspring
to split up this fortune,
as the GDP grows these
people's investments
will grow even faster passively.
Overtime, this family will
grow to own more and more
of the nation's wealth
without really having to do anything.
It almost creates this nobility class
and obviously that's what,
at least many people in the United States
view as what's different about America
relative to old Europe,
to what used to happen
in terms of the French revolution,
and people just inheriting land
generation after generation
and never having to work.
This right here is a quote
from Winston Churchill
on his view of an inheritance tax.
He viewed it as a certain corrective
against the development of
a race of the idle rich.
Anyway, that's the explanation of it.
You can stand for either side of it
but hopefully this at
least gives you the tools
to think about whether
you're for or against it.